So Skype has a central log in server but then use a pier to pier to exchange the
actual voice streams and compresses the audio to achieve a fairly low bit
rate t around 67 bytes per packet and 140 packets per second. We see Skype uses
about 40 kilobites per second in each direction.
Data packets are also encrypted in both directions.
Good audio compression and avoiding hops
through faraway hosts can improve the quality
of the audio, as can for arrow correction. Ultimately, though, the network is
a major factor. Long propagation delays High congestion, or disruptions as
a result of routing changes can all degrade the quality of a voice over IP call.
To ensure that some streams achieve acceptable
performance levels, we sometimes use what's called
Quality of Service. One way of doing
Quality of Service is through explicit resservations.
But, another way is to simply mark
certain packet streams as higher priorities than
others. Let's first take a look at
marking and policing of traffic sending rates.